du wirst ein zauberer mit großartiger
kraft aber du verlierst dein
geschlechtsteil
servus eskildsen herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video heute spielen wir mal
yoopress debatten punkt kommt das ist
eine website die sieht so aus und man
hat die immer vorschläge zum beispiel
here to start off the pearl sliders neue
person anzufangen aber you will have no
memories of the past life also man hat
keine erinnerung an seine vergangenheit
oder muss man sich immer entscheiden
findet man das cool dann tut man den
roten button oder ein ort dann drückt
man das hier oben ich hab das heute in
einem video von justin gesehen deshalb
noch mal verlinkt und dann justin
gefragt ob es cool ist welches aber mach
ma jo klar macht doch deswegen machen
wir das jetzt mal ich glaube da gibt
ganz coole sachen und elend mich auch
besser kennen irgendwo war ja sehen
welche entscheidung nicht treffen würde
aber passt also auf was ich machen kann
wenn man es so macht kann man jäger
disney so etwas ist trippelt ende drei
tage später okay gut genug ist dann
immer für euch also here to start ob er
seine post eine neue person anfangen
aber ich habe keine erinnerung meine
vergangenheit nein will ich nicht ich
will ich will sein wird ich bin okay
hier half life bekommt alpha 3 kommt
raus aber ich kann es nicht spielen und
kann nur kleinen kindern dabei zusehen
wie sie es spielen ohne es zwischen
haydn 830 mega egal leute deswegen award
wisst ihr was upgraden die ganze sache
jetzt man ja machen das so walter ich
sehe die dinge ganz anders kommen
ein display oben sehen jetzt am beach
wieder um direkte machen speech in
meiner brille und bassist mich wieder
mit irgendeinem teppich im browser auf
und ab okay gut yoga oder adventure
immer geht auf ein abenteuer aber das
abenteuer besteht darin dass man im
supermarkt geht gibt es auch gute sachen
50 prozent mehr auf ein abenteuer obwohl
es nur der supermarkt einkauf ist ok ok
with it looks also du siehst gut aus
aber dein größter feind ist dein chef
und zwar für dein ganzes leben
da hab ich bock drauf ja klar 250
prozent wollen nur gut aussehen obwohl
der chef der feind ist mein trick ist
einfach meine eigene geschäft an und ich
bin selbstständig
dann kann es am egal ob der chef florist
wobei dann ist man selbst sein eigener
chef
dann ist man zu sich selbst ein
arschloch leute trotzdem drauf
world of what you get wet and hot school
of which the city also man darf die
hogwarts schule besuchen
aber man ist von nun an blind drauf an
der hogwarts es gibt lockt auch einen
zauber der blindheit teilt also da
sollte - mehr anstrengen nur 43 2 nach
obwohl sie blind sind
genau hier da unten steht am usa kennt
fix sei es wichtig hier jemand anderen
verliebt und der dieser person treu nein
natürlich nicht dann habe ich den rest
meines lebens herzschmerz kein bock
ok jetzt ist jetzt wieder im 21 du wirst
ein zauberer mit großer kraft aber du
verlierst dein geschlechtsteil altar
leute ich habe gerade mit dem fuß das
pedal an meinem stuhl ausgelöst mit dem
man so nach unten sinkt und man bei
einfach des todes eingeklemmt alter mann
ok wollen ein großartiger zauber sein
ohne oder kann man sich doch locker auch
zaubern man kann sich doch kein
geschlechtsteil wieder dran zaubern oder
sowie sowie voldemort kennt die szene
aus was ist der feuerkelch wo voldemort
peter petty grüne künstliche hand zauber
die dann so seeblick schimmert das kann
man bestimmt auch mit schlechten so
machen
ich ziehe mir die brille wieder ab
gerade mit bloggern gemacht für die
seite weil die ganze so nervige werbung
dann kam als guter youtube als vorbild
habe ich ihnen wie die adword nicht an
aber für die seite muss uns jetzt kurz
mal machen mit einer letzte sache noch
du bist in der lage ist in der lage
alles zu machen jeder zeit die ganze
welchen umständen
du kannst alles machen was du willst
alles zu jeder zeit aber die person die
du liebst hat auch diese fähigkeiten und
sie hasst dich und wird andauernd
versuchen dich umzubringen
uns hat die gleichen fähigkeiten
ja aber wenn sie alles machen kann hier
einfach sagen wo ich will den töten dann
ist er tot oder lebendig machen wir
nicht bauen nicht und 7 50 prozent
hätten es auch nicht gemacht
okay leute das war's soweit mal vor
dieser folge wenn euch die sache
gefallen hat ich werde jetzt nicht allzu
lang machen dann schreibt man die
kommentare was ihr davon haltet eure
entscheidungen zu den einzelnen fragen
wir sehen uns beim nächsten spiel wieder
biss dann macht's gut und setzten um
eine sonnenbrille auf